well you know lots of people think it's
important that robe ritual on Sunday so
this would be that for me the there has
been an official announcement there have
been some speculation for a little while
now about the premiere date of Doctor
Who and it is gonna be primary the new
series the it is gonna be premiering
October which we knew we now have a
title for the first episode which I'll
get to in a minute and we also have a
date and it is a Sunday I believe
October 7th I believe it is it's
whatever's the first Sunday in October
and that has apparently thrown some
folks off I the perspective that I'm
able to lend to this is unfortunately
not gonna be the most informed because I
would imagine that the decision to move
Doctor Who from its traditional Saturday
airing day to a Sunday airing day is
probably most being driven by the
ratings and viewer numbers in the UK
which obviously I don't have an inside
track on that I don't know what is you
know standard for weekend viewing what I
know I don't know if my experience as an
American and knowing you know what tends
to air on weekends and how those things
do if it is at all a reflection of what
goes on in the UK I have no clue so if
you want that kind of perspective for
why they might be doing it as far as the
rate he's going and I don't I make a
point of not talking about the ratings I
really never kind of want to talk about
the ratings because I just I don't care
like I only care insofar as if the
ratings ever drop enough that it gets
cancelled yeah I'll care about that but
the specifics of it and even the trends
of it I it's more of a oh yeah okay but
the numbers have been dropping on the
last few years and different people will
point to different things some people
will point to oh it's agenda leading
some people will go well the shows not
very good anymore
some people will go well you know they
went a year with basically no episodes
and did
and instead we only got two Christmas
specials in a row and the show lost
momentum which out of those three that
I've mentioned I think has the most
validity but you know there's a there's
a cavalcade of reasons why shows lose
ratings but and so I bat end of things
now I'm not gonna focus too much on what
I can tell you is that for me personally
it's kind of a good thing
I mean it's slightly annoying because it
means that while new episodes are airing
normally Sunday is my Doctor Who day and
Wow episodes are airing if that's gonna
shift to Monday because I'm not gonna do
two days in a row of Doctor Who so that
is gonna break up how I normally do it
but as soon as it's done airing I'll go
back to putting Doctor Who on Sunday
again so it's not a big deal it does
make my life easier insofar as if it was
going to air on a Saturday and it was my
intention to have it have a review up on
a Sunday there are some weekends that
would have been basically just really
disruptive because a little peek behind
the curtain
alternating weekends I either have my
daughter and the weekends that I don't
more often than not I am off seeing my
partner Liz so that that would mean that
I am away from the means I have to watch
Doctor Who as well as the means to
record a video now normally when I spend
a weekend with her I'm back on Sunday
night so if it's airing on Sunday I
could watch it on Sunday and have
something ready for Monday the next
morning because I can turn these videos
around pretty quick so that works for me
it means I'm not gonna have to figure
out any weird things or be late with
reviews which I wouldn't particularly
want to do either so for me personally
it works out well I guess there are some
folks who are up in arms I guess for
reasons of tradition if nothing else
because doctor who has a very long
history of airing on Saturdays not even
during exclusively the modern era most
from what I can tap from what I can find
most of classic era Doctor Who aired on
Saturday not always there were some
exceptions here and there and obviously
the Christmas special link
whenever Christmas is and it's not oh is
Sunday so you know there are exceptions
but by-and-large doctor who is thought
of as a Saturday show and it's not gonna
be that anymore now again this is an
American perspective I'm about to put on
this but what I can tell you is that in
the u.s. at least stuff that airs
actually not only on Saturdays but also
on Fridays tends to be for a lack of a
better term well it tends to be one of
two things
it tends to be things aimed at an older
demographic because basically the
presumption is that these are the days
that people who are still you know at
the point in their life where they want
to go out and do stuff on the weekend
they're out Friday and Saturday so and
the again in the u.s. at least shows
that era on Fridays and Saturdays it's
either wear shows go to die especially
on Fox for a while was called the Friday
night death slot and whenever a show got
moved to Friday night that was basically
taken as the oh that means it'll be
canceled next year and you know
Saturdays are only slightly better than
that and by and large it's it's a place
to dump cheap you know
shows that are not that expensive to
make and have an appeal that isn't the
norm that isn't the core demographic of
you know the 18 to 35 which is where
most advertisers usually like to get at
especially would you know with something
that they're trying to build you know
big franchise appeal out of now again I
have no idea if that carries over to the
UK or not but if it does at all gonna
move to Sunday at the very least I can't
imagine would be a big detriment would
be a big hit potentially it would be a
boost because you know while you have
your weekend doing something you don't
go out on Sunday night because you've
got work or school or university or
what-have-you
the following day so you know doing
something on a Sunday night you know
that's when you you you'll wind down
here you go oh look at that
I'll watch Doctor Who and I thought you
can talk to my work for
about it on Monday or you know what have
you now that's theoretical that's not an
automatic you know this will get us
better ratings but I'm kind of up the
opinion it can't hurt because I don't
and as much as I know people get hung up
on the tradition of things you know oh
it's always but it should stay that cuz
that's what we've always had I do
understand that I do I understand
there's there's a nostalgia and there's
a tradition involved in that but I mean
can we completely honest is there
anybody who's going to stop watching the
show because it's airing on a Sunday
instead of a Saturday like for that
reason specifically because that strikes
me as really weird I have a really hard
time wrapping my head around the idea
that moving a show for Monday to the to
the next someone who likes the show
something as well now I'm not gonna
watch that and I just I that makes no
sense to me so again I can't imagine
it'll hurt so moving on from that we
also have the title of the first episode
which is going to be the woman who fell
to earth which is a cool title and I
like it given where things left off with
Jodie Whitaker's first appearance in
twice palm time it's very literal then
last we saw her she was falling to earth
out of the TARDIS so yeah there's that
but there's also the illusion of the
name because the man who fell to earth
is a David Bowie film where he was an
alien and it's that's kind of a cool
thing to be alluding to and I I like
that connection that the title makes so
I don't have too many other thoughts
about that title other than like yeah
okay I suspect there are some people who
gonna be annoyed by it because it's
putting the fact that the doctor is now
a woman like in the title so like their
show me it more in our face like look at
her it the doctor is now a woman I don't
know how that's shoving it in your face
more but I wouldn't be surprised if some
people are kind of
pulling that that reaction to it which I
mean I I have my own concerns and I've
expressed some of them already in other
videos about potentially you know the
writing over emphasizing the gender
shift which I would like honestly to get
almost no notice whatsoever
I would like basically nobody to dwell
on this but that's me and if it does get
overly dwelled on that'll be a drag but
I'm not gonna take the title as an
indicator that that is what is going to
happen because I can point to what it's
alluding to and it's alluding to a cool
sci-fi movie starring a really awesome
person I'm okay with that so I think
that's about it I just wanted to get my
thoughts out there now that we have an
airdate and now that we have a title and
get people's thoughts on it do you do
you read a lot into its moved from
Saturday to Sunday cuz I mean I don't
doubt it's a move to attempt to help the
ratings but again I don't focus a lot on
the ratings I I never have I never will
so you know that that's not something
that that I'm all that concerned with
but as far as that goes
what are your thoughts the title what
are your thoughts whatever they are drop
them down in the comments let's talk
about them there's a whole bunch of
stuff to do because there's buttons and
there's links you can subscribe and
support me on patreon and do a whole
bunch of other stuff as well check them
out if you care and remember folks you
are the council I just run the meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]